[Musique]
je me prénomme Valérie Noël j'ai 42 ans
l'entreprise s'appelle
andyeduc.re
et nous faisons
l'accompagnement éducatif et aux actes
de la vie quotidienne des enfants et
adultes en situation de handicap à
domicile historique j'ai lancé le projet
déjà pour avoir une idée de l'impact à
la Startup Weekend euh en
2012 et puis
après je me suis rapprochée du jipsap du
conseil général euh qui est de la maison
de du service à la personne qui m'ont
orienté pour la demande d'agrément au
niveau de la la direction du travail et
j'ai euh par la suite une fois que mon
dossier d'agrément a été déposé j'ai
j'ai sollicité réun active je suis
passée en commission j'ai eu un prêt
nacre accouplé à un prêt
[Musique]
bancaire depuis un an on accompagne plus
de 40 familles donc 20 avec un
dispositif une vingtaine avec le
dispositif du conseil général
départemental du répier repos
et l'autre moitié c'est directement avec
les
familles nous employons à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui 10
éducateurs éducateurs spécialisés et
moniteur éducateur sur toute l'île
souvent c'est les parents se retrouvent
sans solution de garde en dehors de des
heures institutionnelles ou de l'école
et personne veut garder ses enfants mais
par peur donc nous on est là pour
combler ce manque on cherchait en fait
qu'une babysur et finalement avec
Valérie c'est vrai que le domaine s'est
élargi on s'est rendu compte que au-delà
de le garder elle nous a beaucoup aidé
moi j'ai j'ai j'ai souvent dit elle nous
a boosté c'est le seul mot que que j'ai
souvent employé pour Valérie parce que
c'est vrai qu'elle a su non seulement le
garder mais tenir compte de sa
différence et parfois elle nous disait
souvent mais il est capable de faire
certaines choses donc c'est vrai que ça
a été au-delà d'une simple garde
[Musique]
d'enfants j'ai participé au Challenge
des créateurs d'une parce que c'est le
conseil départemental donc pour moi
c'est un
acteur un partenaire indispensable la
Réunion moi j'y suis arrivée il y a 13
ans mais mon conjoint réunionnait donc
on on a notre vie ici mes enfants sont
est ici forcément bah plein de parents
me disent bah tu tu es plus oreilles tu
es créole maintenant alors c'est vrai
que je parle pas le créole mais je le
comprends bien et je trouve normal de
développer l'emploi si si si ça peut
aider il y a pas de souci et c'est mon
pays d'adoption c'est ma région
[Musique]
d'adoption